the declaration of support for United
Nations reform began as a way to give
momentum to secretary-general Guterres
efforts to bring greater efficiency
accountability and transparency to the
UN we thought that having member states
put their names on a document would help
ensure that these goals don't remain
just words but become a part of the
culture of the UN the response that
we've had has been nothing short of
fantastic 128 nations have signed on to
the declaration as of this morning and
we're still counting that is a
supermajority I thank our co-hosts today
our friends from Canada Germany
Indonesia Japan Jordan Nigeria Wanda
Senegal Slovakia Thailand the United
Kingdom and Uruguay most of all I thank
all of you the fact that so many are
committed to sing the United Nations
succeed is gratifying it is a sign not
only that change is desperately needed
but that it will be achieved you were
the reason change is coming to the UN it
is now my honor to introduce someone who
is no stranger to change Donald Trump
has a business man's eye for seeing
potential and he sees great potential
not just in this reform movement but in
the United Nations itself he shares your
commitment to creating a more effective
advocate for peace security and human
rights we are deeply grateful he has
taken the time to be with us today
ladies and gentlemen president Donald J
Trump well thank you very much thank you
I actually saw a great potential right
across the street to be honest with you
and it was only for the reason that the
United Nations was here that that turned
out to be such a successful project so I
want to thank you ambassador Haley for
your introduction and for your steadfast
advocacy for American interests on the
world stage on behalf of the co-host
countries I would like to also thank
secretary-general GU turis for and you
have been fantastic for joining us and
we affirm our commitment to the United
Nations reform and reform is what we're
talking about I applaud the
secretary-general for laying out a
vision to reform the United Nations so
that it better serves the people we all
represent we support your efforts to
look across the entire system and to
find ways the United Nations can better
and be better at development management
peace and security the United Nations
was founded on truly noble goals
these include affirming the dignity and
worth of the human person and striving
for international peace the United
Nations has helped advance toward these
goals in so many ways feeding the hungry
providing disaster relief and empowering
women and girls and many societies all
across the world yet in recent years the
United Nations has not reached its full
potential because of bureaucracy and
mismanagement while the United Nations
on a regular budget has increased by 140
percent and its staff has more than
doubled since 2000 we are not seeing the
results in line with this investment but
I know that under the secretary-general
that's changing and it's changing fast
and we've seen it that's why we commend
the secretary-general and is call for
the United Nations to focus more on
people
and less on bureaucracy we seek a United
Nations that regains the trust of the
people around the world in order to
achieve this the United Nations must
hold every level of management
accountable protect whistleblowers and
focus on results rather than on process
to honor the people of our nations we
must ensure that no one and no member
state shoulders
a disproportionate share of the burden
and that's militarily or financially we
also ask that every peacekeeping mission
have clearly defined goals and metrics
for evaluating success they deserve to
see the value in the United Nations and
it is our job to show it to them we
encourage the secretary-general to fully
use his authority to cut through the
bureaucracy reform outdated systems and
make firm decisions to advance the UN's
core mission further we encourage all
Member States to look at ways to take
bold stands at the United Nations with
an eye toward changing business as usual
and not being beholden to ways of the
past which were not working mr.
secretary-general the United States and
the member states present today support
this great reform vision we pledge to be
partners in your work and I am confident
that if we work together and champion
truly bold reforms the United Nations
will emerge as a stronger more effective
more just in greater force for peace and
harmony in the world Thank You mr.
secretary-general and I look forward to
advancing the shared goals in the years
to come and it is a great honor to be
with you today thank you